normalement je suis rigolote je fais
plein de blagues je suis la reine des
grimaces et j'adore faire rire mes
copines anodine et deux filles
j'ai toujours aimé faire rire faire des
spectacles à la fin des vacances d'été
avec mes soeurs mes frères nos cousins
on imitait des groupes à la mode
les babys kylie minogue on avait tous
les t-shirts wiki qui les chaussures
fido dido et nos rêves rires faire rire
pourtant ce n'était pas gagné parce
qu'il y a rapidement plein de trucs qui
sont venus me pourrir la vie
comme j'avais dix ans j'ai mis tout ça
dans un seul bloc et j'ai appelé ça le
monstre pas besoin de détails rien que
le mot monstre doit évoquer chez vous
quelque chose de pas forcément agréable
et c'était le cas cette année là donc je
prends l'avion avec ma soeur mes grands
parents
direction la corse du sud bonifacio
c'est l'heure du déjeuner et on nous
sert du poisson et des arêtes dans ma
petite tête de petites filles je fait
les cent pas cérébraux je vais
m'étouffer avec les arrête
c'est sûr il n'y a pas de médecin je
suis tout seul
coincé dans un avion je vais étouffé et
mourir je n'avais jamais pensé à cela
auparavant j'avais jamais avalé de
travers mais en y repensant bien plus
tard si j'en ai avalé des truc de
travers est bien plus douloureux que des
arts est assise à ma place je regarde le
poisson que je vais marcher pendant des
heures pour en faire des boules et les
recracher dans la serviette en papier
c'est le début d'une technique
mettre les choses à la bouche ne pas
avaler et recracher le tout là où je
peux j'ai sans cesse les mains souillées
que je dois tout le temps essuyé quelque
part j'ai honte mais personne ne voit
rien ou années de ma rentrée de sixième
je sens que j'ai un problème je perçois
même le danger que je cours comme je
n'ai pas les moyens ni l'envié d'en
parler à quiconque je choisis de lire
pour comprendre ce qui m'arrive je
découvre les mots pour le dire de marie
cardinal
c'est un livre autobiographique qui
retrace cette année de psychanalyse et
de souvenirs d'une enfance douloureuse
cette enfance traumatisante se traduit
par des pertes de sang inexpliqué je ne
comprends pas grand chose à ce que j
j'ai toujours dix ans et je ne sais pas
ce que c'est que d'avoir des règles à
mais je sens que quelque chose déconne
chez moi j'ai en permanence la sensation
d'une barre de fer dans la gorge et la
phobie de tous les aliments long
spaghetti haricots verts et par
extension tout ce qui est filandreux les
mots pour le dire mais je les ai pas
comme marie cardinal
elle a ses pertes de sang et moi barre
de fer dans le gosier points mais ça
fait mal si mal que je décide d'en
parler à maman qui m'emmène voir un orl
bien sûr le spécialiste ne voit rien et
nous repartons moi avec ma barre de fer
invisible et maman avec un petit
soulagement
je m'arrange pour ne plus trop parler de
cette barre de fer je suis forte
je suis une petite fille gaie je ris je
travaille bien je joue beaucoup
je ne veux pas inquiéter mes parents ils
ont aussi leurs soucis je ne veux pas en
rajouter une couche
et puis ça soit pas tant que ça à ma
barre de fer je continue de me réfugier
dans mes lectures
ça ne soulage pas à ma douleur mais ça
me permet d'être moins seul face au mal
qui me ronge
quelques mois plus tard donc en classe
de cinquième je découvre l'herbe bleue
le journal intime d'une drogue et 15 ans
je ne me drogue pas et la drogue ne
m'intéresse pas je joue encore aux
barbies la fille finit par mourir après
quelques séjours en asile psychiatrique
et elle termine par ces mots tout a été
pour le mieux je pense mais d'une
manière spéciale salut à bientôt
c'est gai les mots pour le dire
ben les a pas eu non plus ou alors ils
ont dû partir en fumée comme ma barre de
fer qui se fait tantôt la malle il qui
revient sans savoir pourquoi ni comment
j'ai un peu de répit je vais en profiter
pour souffler puis pour avaler deux ou
trois trucs parce qu'elle va revenir et
ça va se corser
et c'est pas d'une barre de fer qui
revient mais départ pas jean classe de
première littéraire dans une classe de
filles seulement deux filles ont toutes
des problèmes de filles bien élevées des
pressions roman c'est l'hystérie de
circonstance sexualité in progress
mais moi je m'enfonce dans un truc qui
m'échappe complètement je ne mange plus
je ne trouve de salut que dans l'art qui
à ce moment là de mon existence met en
scène ma vie intérieure chaotique et
bouleversé je comprends que mon mal à
être peut se raconter peut se jouer
c'est ma bouée toujours en classe de
première je découvre la taganka russe
l'équivalent de la comédie française
elle joue l'oeuvre de dostoïevski crime
et châtiment
l'histoire de ce jeune étudiant russe
raskolnikov quitus à prêteur sur gages
et toutes les conséquences physiques
émotionnels et psychologiques que ce
crime va avoir sur le hero c'est gai
aussi j'assiste au spectacle avec ma
soeur mon papa et ma meilleure amie
sur scène les comédiens sont nombreux
ils parlent fort c'est violent comme une
barre de fer j'étouffe mais personne ne
ressent mon malaise ça ne se voit pas
tant que ça mais je sens que je vais
crever à ce moment très précis je
bascule je m'enfonce et ça se voit et ça
se sait l'infirmière de l'internât du
lycée je suis interne depuis la seconde
crache le morceau et appelle mes parents
au réfectoire le soir les surveillants
ne supporte plus les sculptures que je
fais avec ma nourriture c'est
l'affolement
les rendez vous chez les psys les
médecins lexomil prozac
je suis un légume a battu qui résiste
c'est une maman qui paniquent
un beau père qui ne comprend pas trop et
un papa trop loin
la suite s'appelle troubles du
comportement alimentaire
je vais aller de thérapie en thérapie
que je vais sa beauté de traitement en
traitement que je ne vais pas prendre
j'irai mal mais pas trop la littérature
les spectacles ne me suffisent plus à
comprendre voyager dans les livres à ses
limites
je ressens la nécessité d'aller voyager
pour de vrai et si mon voyage intérieur
sortait de ses frontières
à 17 ans le bac en poche et l'entrée à
l'université assuré je décide de faire
un long voyage salon voyage organisé par
un prof de mon lycée en chine mongolie
russie
mes parents n'ont pas eu d'autre choix
que d'accepter ma décision
il fallait que je m'éloigne pour
comprendre le trouble dans lequel
j'étais et l'asie c'est pas mal loin je
découvre le monde du haut de mes 17 ans
et peu à peu j'oublie de compter les
calories et les kilomètres que je dois
faire pour prendre un peu plus presque
deux mois à sortir de moi même à
m'intéresser à autre chose qu'aux gras
des aliments de l'air je prends l'air je
vis des situations inédites pour une
jeune de mon âge je [ __ ] sur la place
tiananmen à pékin
je voyage dans le transsibérien jeu par
le russe à des hommes d'affaires dans
des hôtels luxueux jeu chevauchent les
steppes mongoles et je bois même du lait
de jument fermenté et ça c'est vraiment
infecte
ça pourrait être une épreuve à koh lanta
j'ai conscience que ce que je vis est un
énorme cadeau
alors je mens kittin plus avec la
nourriture à quoi ça sert de remuer le
passé si ce n'est à pas aprecié le
présent cette pensée et guérisseuse je
trouve ma part d'humanité et de
générosité
les visages des gens m'invitent à
m'assoupir à ouvrir mes bras à tendre
l'oreille à regarder d'un peu plus près
à laisser mon coeur s'est penché quelque
chose a changé même si je sais cette
chose fragile
je ne suis pas dupe mais je sais quel
chemin prendre pour y arriver
que ce soit à des milliers de kilomètres
de ma famille ou ici en france des
voyages j'en referai en afrique en
lituanie pour enseigner le français
pendant mes études supérieures durant
mes vacances j'ai le goût de l'autre je
commence à comprendre que je peux faire
quelque chose qui compte même un tout
petit peu peut-être que je commence
aussi à compter quelque part dans
l'univers mes problèmes alimentaires
vont me [ __ ] la paix je suis pas
dingue de moi mais je gère à ma façon je
cours beaucoup je suis devenue
végétarienne pas par amour des bêtes
mais pour fuir le gras je ris je danse
j'ai des amoureux un peu une vie normale
à 22 ans diplômé de l'institut des
langues orientales de l'iscom une école
de communication et de l'école de
journalisme de marseille
je rencontre celui qui deviendra le père
de mes trois filles et qui me redonnera
nous véritablement à la nourriture
j'ai choisi un homme qui sait très bien
cuisiner
mais problème alimentaire semble
s'éloigner vraiment mais c'est pour
mieux me retrouver
c'est pour mieux me tester le jour où je
décide de donner la vie bah ouais je
croyais m'en être sorti avec mes voyages
ma littérature mes spectacles je suis
grande je fais ce que j'ai à faire je
bosse j'aime et j'ai arrêté de me poser
dix mille questions mais suffisant pour
être bien avec la vie mais trois
grossesses me rendent très malade
jusqu'à perdre beaucoup de poids jusqu'à
4 mois de grossesse frôlant ainsi
l'hospitalisation mais du poids j'en
prendrais et j'accoucherai de trois
beaux bébés rose et dodu en pleine santé
ça va et puis pour retrouver ma ligne je
saurai ma femme et je sais faire j'ai la
technique tout est sous mon contrôle
un contrôle que je vais finir par perdre
le jour de la naissance de notre
troisième fille irène irène signifie la
paix et c'est exactement ce que je
ressens le jour de son arrivée sur terre
je me fous enfin la paix j'ai alors 35
ans et ça fait depuis l'âge de 16 ans
que je suis en guerre contre moi même il
est temps pour moi de baisser les armes
pourquoi je décide de baisser les armes
à ce moment là parce que je décide
d'écouter ma petite voix intérieure et
je sais qu'à ce moment là elle saura
mener à être pleinement moi même les
études les voyages la littérature m'ont
aidé à tenir bon a plié sans céder à
résister à survivre
écoutez ma petite voix intérieure a fait
de moi une femme debout une femme qui
vit je commence à a accepté celle que je
suis vraiment avec tout ce que j'ai été
je commence à comprendre qu'il ya un
chemin pour transformer les blessures en
cicatrices qu'as-tu donc fait de ton
talent cédant la bible et c'est
exactement ce que me dit ma petite voix
intérieure d'honorer mon talent je suis
rigolote vous souvenez eh ben ça va
savoir
à 37 ans je décide de quitter mon job et
15 ans d'une vie professionnelle intense
mais somme toute normale pour écrire mon
spectacle
c'est un truc drôle et le jouer et je
joue parce que j'en ai envie depuis des
années parce que faire rire les autres
ça me fait kiffer parce que je veux que
chaque jour soit des spectacles de fin
d'été pour prolonger le bonheur dans les
yeux de mes parents je crois pas au
hasard
il n'y a pas de hasard je suis pas sur
scène par hasard j'ai toujours voulu que
la vie soit une fête qu'elle soit drôle
julie légère qu'elle rassemble c'est mon
chemin de résilience on a tous un chemin
de résilience
il est parfois pas facile à trouver
épineux vous fait prendre des détours
mais il est là et il n'attend que vaut
pas pour vous guider vers votre plein
d'authenticité faire rire c'est jouir à
l'instant plus question d'aller
farfouiller dans le passé faire rire me
permet d'accepter ce qui a été et d'être
dans le présent avec joie
j'ai cessé de vouloir me venger du passé
le jour où je suis monté sur scène pour
jouer mon premier sketch je m'en
souviens comme si c'était hier
c'était il ya presque deux ans à la
royal factory de versailles là où je vis
il y avait tous les gens que j'aime
autour de moi ceux d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui formant la force du
présent en faisant rire j'ai mis les
blessures à distance et laisser un peu
plus de place à l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
à l'amour des autres et pour les autres
alors oui un monstre est toujours un peu
là c'est vrai mais j'ai appris à lui
pardonner de m'avoir fait mal et même
aller mais c'est beaucoup moins
douloureux est beaucoup plus heureux
libérez délivrés
désormais plus rien ne m'arrête délivré
libéré terminé les princesses parfaite
non je suis là comme je lai rêver je
suis là comme je lai rêver parole de
reine des neiges
merci